good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday our
favorite day of the week here at the
morning toast home day
make sure to hump someone you love for
me it's gonna be my dog Theo because
he's so supportive and wonderful and he
deserves a good old fashioned humping
for all the talk that you talk of
humping Theo I don't think he's ever
actually been here on a Wednesday on a
hump day because he's yesterday he'll be
roaming around doing his thing you know
making sure all the courts are plugged
in so he's running point on tech for us
today
you might see him in the stream later on
if you're lucky he's our Pio ta you know
going on tech you know who else you're
gonna see in a stream today who Reza
Farhan yes you are because we actually
do something we never do but because of
Reza's schedule we were willing to do
anything to get him on the show like I'm
his number one fan and I feel like it
was so worth the accommodations we made
for him usually we don't pre-recorded
episodes because we're the morning toast
live hello so normally we won't but if
it's like a guest that we would die
without we'll make arrangements so we
recorded a really fun episode with Reza
last night that if you're listening as a
podcast you're none the wiser and it'll
all be connected for you but if you're
watching on YouTube the video has
already been uploaded so when you're
done with this episode you can check out
our very premium interview with Reza we
spoke all about the MJ fight the years
of Shahs of Sunset the Lilly ghalichi of
it all like a standard of Claudia sure
oh my god by the way on TMZ talking
about resin yeah Claudia on TMZ and it
was just like such a great moment like
for you for me and I think for rez I
think had a good time I think he did too
I think he's skeptical when he came in
here as many people are many but I think
you really want him over and he brought
us his haircare line
he left the pomade by the way I saved it
for know I know I'm gonna give it to
Zack and I'm also we use the same hair
product so it's like for Zack and I but
then I get to say I got you something
right and I actually just love a pomade
for a woman like I think that not enough
women are using pomade and I think a lot
of people struggle with the same issue
like frizzy hair like flyaways and
nobody realized that the answer is
pomade no this is such a good point
you're raising I always do a high bun
and people ask how do you not have
flyaways I'm like I have more flyways
than you like I have so many broken
hairs pomade is the answer for
everything it's also we put it on our
parts every morning that's why I mean we
do have naturally shiny hair but it
makes it even shinier yeah and it's it's
literally like I feel like I've only
realized
important a pomade is to your full
finished look in the last month and I I
look back at pictures and my hair was so
unkept and I just thought I had bad hair
like nobody has good hair everyone's
using a pomade and no one's been telling
me about it
yes this is true they've all been
meeting behind your back I just used a
color well one that Chris Appleton gave
us right before I put a little in my
hand how amazing is that one really good
one Mel's great that's the one that I
always use but now I have this recipe
obsessed when I'm excited I'm excited to
use both I use orange thing is too much
pomade
no keep on slicking it in I use the
Armco one I just don't like the residue
it leaves in my hair afterwards like the
color red one in a few hours like it's
totally gone yeah it's very watery like
putting a good win yeah yeah but in a
good way anything Chris Appleton tells
you to do you do it cuz did you see J
Lo's hair at the Super Bowl looking
mighty fine
like that was some of the top 5 hair
I've ever seen in my life and on any red
carpet many movie anything and another
one of my top 5 moments was JLo doing
press for the Super Bowl like two days
before where she did a very sleek shiny
midi-length hair with like a full curl
at the bottom it like curled and it was
just stellar very old Hollywood glam I
love a curl in me too Wow okay so we
have a great show for you today actually
of stories that I do feel passionately
about we have Vanderpump rules recap we
have dear toasters and then we have our
Reza Farhan segment yeah so I feel like
we should get right into it but I feel
like there was also a million other
things I was gonna say no not for me I
had a very low-key night with my husband
my roses my husband and obviously my son
and my roses actually my son like no no
slight to Ben but Theo is my world no I
completely agree like no sight to my
husband but my nephew is my world and
look how good he's being right now by
the way full updates so since we're
updating you on all the things happening
with our studio you know we have our new
cameras our new 1080p which people seem
to be loving we are very happy about
that we have furniture on its way and we
also have some equipment on the way to
get us to set up for our th EO cam I
don't to say his name because he's
asleep but we're working on getting the
you know cam set up because it was so
popular back in the day it really was
also I just want to say we were talking
about my shoes before the show and I
just feel like I need to share with the
class I just got these shoes this
weekend I love them and they're from H&M
they're sickening when you walked in
here I was like let me have this [ __ ]
and her problem again she's getting like
the lens did like the Balenciaga like
cool like dad shoes
I actually I saw them a nation em I love
them and they're on sale right now and I
just feel like if you're interested and
I don't own any of these like what are
they called like dad shoes I'm chunky
stompers this is my first pair and it
was a great foray into Dino stomping is
it annoying if I get a pair not at all
okay to me that's like the highest
compliment and it's a compliment but
it's definitely annoying it I like when
we nach lai chi think it's like SoCo for
sure I just want to point out like how
we've role reverse today like I'm over
here with my Gucci shoes and you're with
your H&M sneakers thanks I'm still
wearing off like another moose your
update that I want to just plug really
quickly is that at noon today we're
having a merge drop and it's the dirty
jeans tour March so if you came to a
show and there wasn't much oh you forgot
to get merch or you didn't come to a
show but you wanted to when you wanted
merge all the customers that we had made
for my final show with the beacon is
available in limited stock let me just
show you a few items if I may I just
feel like it would be nice if I could
get a visual of this premium merch I
chose two things to show because they're
my favorite this white long-sleeve shirt
first of all is so sick but hello this
is a large obviously and I think it goes
up to extra-large
yeah of course but before you do just
one sec I think it's important this is
the only item that has all the tour
dates on the back which is like so
ariana grande of me like am i well and
this is yours oh my god I got you want
actually I have the perfect way to wear
today but I also just want to say where
is it Tarrytown of course bramma you
shouldna you should put a big red circle
around Verona because that was you oh
wait that looks so cute
so everyone show Jackie do it do a twirl
tour dates in the back business in the
front
very cute looking good okay and then
because we know the toasters we can make
all the merch we want they just want big
oversized sweaters so that's what I made
for you this sweatshirt says Claudia are
a dirty Jean store comes in pink and
yellow and it says on the back up in the
neck
Durr you can theater generationally Beth
and it's super cute this is in
extra-large right yes oh no it's a
medium I'm gonna skinny mi well it's
oversized so you can wear it as a dress
it's the same type of sweater that we
use for morning toast merch so you can
size the same way and it also comes in a
different style in blue and so I'm gonna
be dropping at shop morning toast calm
at noon eastern time today limited stock
Wow I love how this top just like broke
up my outfit like I was like one it
looks like I was wearing a jumpsuit no
now you really just look like red Oaks
Country Club and you
that's the best time that show on Amazon
was really good and like never returned
remember at red oaks yeah but you know
what I was watching curb the new season
have you started watching I saw the
first episode there's only been two
right there's been four now Wow um and
the dad from red oaks is in oh you know
he's like I don't know who those two
people are they're disagreeing his name
is Andy I think he might be a cousin or
something of Larry's well red oaks was
such a great show and it was two seasons
maybe three on Amazon and it just never
liked God it was glad that it ended
though because they were starting to
leave the country club and the country
club was like closing in stop night and
then they were poor and like that was
sad yeah and like then he was like being
an NYU student with his artsy
girlfriends and it's like no no that's
not the show like I signed up to watch
it's not what we asked for without an
80's Country Club and right and now I'm
just watching like Gossip Girl when they
go to NYU I'm so sorry that that
happened - that's a true tragedy it's
just it's just misleading that's the
thing when you're mislead it's
disappointing because it's misleading
thank you thank you so much okay well I
think it's time that we can just get
right into the Fast Five story is that
you yes you need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast well it is time I think I would be
remiss devastated and heartbroken if I
didn't remind everyone that tax season
very sadly is almost upon us and
TurboTax is here to help this tax season
by making filing easier for you they've
made their they've made it their mission
to give you all the tools and advice you
need to get your taxes done with
confidence like making uploading your
w-2 as easy as taking a picture just use
your phone or tablet to simply snap a
picture of your w-2 and then watch your
information appear in the right place in
your tax return you can be sure you're
filing your taxes the correct way while
at the same time making sure you're
getting the best possible refund
TurboTax all people are tax people Thank
You Trevor tax for sponsoring this
episode of the morning toast you're
truly doing life-saving work out there
and don't get behind on your taxes it's
already February guys it's heavy all
right last night I was thinking about
getting a head start on my taxes so I
did something kind of crazy this year I
already found my taxes I did it at the
end of the year it's when april rolls
around i'm guchi that's so crazy
tax season is really so crazy and
interesting for influencers like not us
cuz like we have our [ __ ] together but
like I don't understand like I don't
know it's actually really hard here
because technically when as an
influencer like you are your own boss
these vendors like paying you and it's
really a lot to keep together it is no
and I always wonder how other people do
it and I would love to like talk to like
an actual successful influencer and be
like how the [ __ ] do you do your taxes
because it's a weird new industry and
there's no like template for how to do
it yeah it's interests like you're a
freelancer but also a self-employed
contractor it's very confusing okay well
let's get into our first story because
Selena Gomez is gonna be happy following
her taxes for her new beauty line rare
beauty I can't so Selena Gomez went live
on Instagram to let us know that she's
launching a beauty line called rare
Beauty I guess it was gonna leak so she
wanted to get it out there herself that
was the most interesting part of the
people are loving to do that yeah and
makes me like who's gonna leak this
yeah it just sucks because like I'm sure
a lot of people and like the brand spend
a lot of time and money like on a launch
idea that is now irrelevant but I do
like when celebrities like cut right in
front of their their threader's yeah and
she she took to Instagram live which I
thought was an interesting choice from
her we usually don't get like long
stretches of Selena and we also don't
get anything really live because she's
so messy like they always give me some
cropped video that they edited
themselves yes so it was not scripted or
anything she talks about how she's been
working on this line for two years it's
gonna be launched with Sephora and it's
about it's like attainable makeup you
know it's there it's for everyone it's I
mean that's the vibe it's she's trying
to put out it's like that makeup and
like beauty can be so intimidating if
you're like not feeling yourself and
this is meant to be like all equal when
by the way that's not exactly a unique
idea like that's what every beauty brand
it's like we're all beautiful like and
it's just like it made me realize it's
like her song who says which is the
greatest song ever who says you're not
perfect he says you're not worth it and
the makeup line should have been called
who says I just feel like I'm really
trying hard not to be like so negative
about this but I every thought I have is
so negative first of all literally
nobody asked like nobody needs this
nobody wants this like did you see like
it's not like she's responsible for some
of the most amazing I think when
celebrities just randomly decide to
launch a makeup line it's very
frustrating but sometimes it makes sense
like when they're responsible like Kim
and Kylie are responsible for like some
of the most iconic moments in glam that
it actually makes sense when Lady Gaga
did it it's like it makes a little less
sense but I don't I don't see it at such
a stretch she's a very clear makeup
look so it's like when she said she was
launching a make up mind I'm like oh I
know exactly what that looks like and
it's like niche because it's really
meant to be like unisex it's really
meant to be for drag like it's very
specific then like Kesha did one it's
like literally nobody asked and it makes
no sense and now Selena Gomez it's like
your career is so weird so messy so all
over the place like you could barely
release your music like why are you
releasing a makeup line now literally
nobody asked for it just is so strange
and it's just it's it's annoying because
I feel like the makeup industry is
becoming so oversaturated that it's like
it's just now you can't even get excited
about new makeup because it's just
happening all the time it's not special
anymore
yeah and plus in combination with all of
the influence or Beauty who write of
lines right and it's just sometimes I
get it like I see the connection where
someone could be connected like Kim and
Kylie like and I know I'm just an
apologist Rihanna yeah like I I get why
I get the idea and the motive behind
launching immediate lines where makeup
lines that we needed and that we who
honestly asked for yeah but like
literally nobody asked for the Selena
Gomez line and it's like it's gonna be
successful just because she's Selena
Gomez and she attached her name to it
but it's just so frustrating for people
who actually like care about makeup I
can't explain why I found it so
frustrating and what I find even more
frustrating is like again another
example of like an audience being their
intelligence like being taken advantage
of in this video she's talking she's
been working on this project for two
years and it's something how she's
always wanted to do meanwhile like the
Sephora collab video had all this
footage of her trying on makeup in two
different sweaters so it was literally
two different meetings yeah so it's
eight years and you did I mean two years
and you tip two meetings I don't know
she had a great sweater and a white
turtleneck like that's it no white off
the shoulder a greater neck I was
noticing I'm like - she have more than
one sweater you know it's been is a film
to meetings like this is not a lifelong
project like literally nobody needed
this and nobody asked for it sorry I'm
being so harsh I'm sure it'll do really
well her fans are super loyal and
they'll buy it and I'm sure it was like
her team was like listen we can do a
beauty line like the damn it the
interest is there not from Claudia ray
and Jackie but from other people though
but also Selena Gomez is a businesswoman
and when you think about it she's only
released two albums and she was the face
of coach but like what else she's got a
pair of bills yeah like being the most
followed person on Instagram and never
posting doesn't exactly pay the bills no
oh you know something interesting that I
don't think we've spoken about mostly
because I haven't watched the Justin
Bieber documentary
but they've been releasing episodes I
think like on a weekly basis or a
bi-weekly basis whatever that means and
one of the episodes recently was all
about time in his life when he was like
really in a bad place like partying a
lot and doing drugs and the timeline
overlaps with this time with Selena and
it's just like how long are we gonna
like all pretend like I just can't we're
close money cool stock I'm done trying
to tell you guys like things don't add
up when Selena Gomez is Taylor Swift's
best friend and Taylor so if he's
bringing out females on stage to sing
shake it off and Selena Gomez's in the
audience and she's a pop star and she's
not on stage it's like one plus one
equals R one plus one equals support
like Paul's he's great but she's a very
new Taylor friend
yes Helena's an OG Selena's an OG like
and she's a pop star why isn't she on
that stage shaking that thing I don't
see you up there shaking that I wouldn't
rather seen her up there shaking that
thing she was not well because it equals
suck because it equals sock okay this
next story is really crazy Jessica
Simpson's book is making headlines every
day and I and I'm so here for I'm not
tired of it did you see her in that pink
trench yesterday of course she was
channeling her inner Elwood's like she
writes one book she said was my copy
arrived yesterday and I'm you know I'm
not much of a reader but I do like to
read on vacation but we've been talking
about this book so much I feel like I
should read it like now I have no trips
plan maybe have to go away this weekend
is just so I could read the book totally
where should I go I don't know we were
gonna plan something we'll talk about it
I'm gonna read this book but I just
finished another book and I have like
something I have to do I can't like read
focus on something else until I'm
finished with yes thing oh do not read
multiple books at the same time um I
would and but if I have to do something
like specific with one of them I just
need all my my mind I understand there
you know like enemies Jessica Simpson
says she turned down the notebook
because of the sex scene oh yeah I heard
this and like don't get me wrong I'm her
number one fan but like I just don't
believe him in her new memoir Jessica
Simpson says she was up for Rachel
McAdams his role in the notebook but
turned it down because of the sex scene
quote I knew exactly what the movie was
about because I had read the script she
writes in her book because she turned it
down because they wouldn't budge on
taking out the sex scene quote and it
would have been with Ryan Gosling of all
people right remember the drama goes
back to when she kissed Justin
Timberlake I knee texted Ryan Gosling
can see we're all on Mickey Mouse Club
together oh my god I forgot that Ryan
Gosling was a Mickey Mouse member that
makes sense when I first read this quote
I was like why
she'd give a [ __ ] if it's Ryan Gosling
like what he's too hot maybe that's what
she was saying just like they were the
connection her first crush
right right right she ended up seeing
the film for the first time on an
airplane at the same moment a statement
went out announcing her separation from
ex Nick Lachey
Oh God I wrote she oh god I thought she
writes the most romantic movie in the
world and I was leading Nick the movie
was on every screen and I was swept up
into it wishing I had that great love
that would be forever
okay so my take here is nothing like she
was you know almost playing Ally but
probably a lot of actresses like heard
about this movie you wanna are you
interested and she just wasn't
interested right yeah no I don't think
it was like between her and Rachel
McAdams but I just don't but I think of
the notebook I don't really think of
like that sex scene as being so crazy
maybe take the floor
yeah like when he rips the tights after
the canoe so it's really not that crazy
it's really not that crazy but it's very
tame actually I couldn't use a little
more but it's it's interesting because I
remember back in the day she was like
that good Christian girl and like
everyone thought that was really an act
but now 20 years later it's like you're
seeing her she actually really was a
good Christian girl yeah and it like it
affected her music and and her selection
of movies yeah um I'm happy for the way
that everything of course was meant to
be right it was Rachel McAdams role like
yeah no one else could have could have
gotten it but very interesting
nonetheless I'm just I'm loving this
book me too I'm just oh my god Vanessa
Lachey and yes they were on the Today
Show and Hoda was masking the important
she was just like doing her job and by
the way she kind of glazed over it she
really asked it as a question she was
like you know yeah Jessica Simpson here
the other day and that amazing partner
book where she says you guys sent her a
gift for her baby and Vanessa Lachey was
like what she couldn't let it go she
took not only once but twice did she
literally correct her and be like I mean
I'm like no shade but like we just like
don't have her address she was being
such a [ __ ] and by the way Nick is like
shut the [ __ ] up sweetie I sent it yeah
it was awkward I don't know what it all
means like obviously it's ten years
later like they're both happily married
be children like there is no active beef
no I never thought so but honestly
Vanessa Lachey was making me think
otherwise
I'm sure she's not happy honestly that
her husband is now in the news so much
as it relates to Jessica Simpson like
it's frustrating they'd been married for
10 years it definitely like feels like
it could like D legitimize their
relationship but there was I thought she
was rude I did did you keep your coffee
nice coffee cup
next to your laundry ingredients oh my
god
because every time I take a sip I'm like
eating a dryer sheet Jackie do you have
the same Jillian yesterday did I say
that my Snapple tastes like detergent I
did oh my god I'm freaking out do you
keep them yeah yeah oh my god we can't
drink this anymore yeah well I think it
might be the cap maybe if I take off the
cap it'll get better
oh my god that's so crazy mine oh dude
this whole show I've been trying to
figure it out I thought maybe your merge
had just been freshly washed oh then I
remember I smelled it when I was over
there you know I keep it above my
washing machine which is where my Tide
Pods are yeah oh my god I'm dead Jackie
I literally had the same thing as her
I'm like maybe it's a bad Snapple I
joined Apple in here like I know
everyone thinks it's like a coffee urn
oh I drink Snapple I'm so glad we got to
the bottom oh my god I feel like you
know when somebody's in your brain and
then someone says something in your
brain it like freaks you out like I'm
just feeling shocked right now yeah no
we see each other that's just so funny
if you haven't watched that Vanessa
Lachey Nick Lachey Today Show thing just
google it it's oh it's on Danny
Pellegrino's Instagram that's why I saw
it and it's crazy as [ __ ] yeah I don't
know what to make of it um I just I
guess but if she didn't buy them a gift
and she's hearing that she did like
maybe she just wants me factually
accurate like I feel like that's
something I would do I know but like to
say in the right live TV it's like no I
do want to like wait we didn't send a
gift yeah but just the way she said it
like I don't like have her address like
she was just being such a [ __ ] like I'm
sure you don't have her address like
your manager I was like you know what I
mean yeah so I think she has a little
black book with Jessica Simpson's
address in it no I just thought I mean
I'm a Jessica Simpson stand so I just
thought that it was really uncool oh and
I went on Jessica Simpson's Instagram
yesterday and this is so random and I'm
not being paid to plug this but if you
buy her audiobook at the end there's six
new songs oh my god why it's just she
was singing along on an Instagram video
to one of her own songs that I went to
spot if I'm like where is the jam and it
wasn't there so night to read the
caption it said at the end of her
audiobook so now my do I have to buy her
audio boomy I'll buy her audiobook
instead of reading it on Kindle I know
it's not interesting it's really
interesting
okay next story also interesting
remember a few months back there was the
golden ratio that told us that the
science viewed the most beautiful woman
in the world based on like you know
age-old proportions and distance from
Bella Hadid Bella Hadid was the most
beautiful who's that a year ago already
no no that was like while we were in LA
um now that same standard has come out
for men oh I saw and the most beautiful
man according to science drumroll please
Robert Pattinson I mean it couldn't have
come at a better time for me as like my
twilight you know Stan Hood is being
rejuvenated yet renewed so this is such
great news and he really does have a
perfect box but the cheekbones in the
chin and the jaw the beard like and the
hair and you know the the the VAM penis
it's just it's perfect I think it's
really interesting so now it's like two
Bella Hadid and Robert Pattinson have to
get together oh my god and then with
their baby be the most beautiful baby
even though like if you think of the
most beautiful people in their world
like their parents weren't supermodels
they were just average people I thought
that's not how genetic work genetics
work yeah and obviously two beautiful
people can have a beautiful child but
when you think of like you know the most
beautiful person in the world
their parents are more often than I'll
just like average looking people it's
true so it's just it's a gamble
okay well guys the rest of the list are
you ready second place is Henry Cavill
oh he's a host so he in my mind don't
know what he's ever been in I think he's
in Sons of Anarchy but he will always be
the guy who was almost 50 shades of grey
and he's so much more of 50 shades of
grey than Jamie Dornan like when you
look at his spot though and to me lay is
not my type but when I look at a picture
of his father just like oh that really
is a perfect touch and when you look at
that Fox you think he should have been
in Fifty Shades of Grey because he's
supposed to be like born in it's like a
scrawny pipsqueak he honestly like that
whole franchise is like a trap but I
think it was made weirder by the fact
that he was totally miscast right and
weirder by the fact that we know that
him into go to Kota Johnson we're not in
love it was nothing of the sort they
didn't like each other and the only
thing that could make like a great love
story amazing is when the leads are in
love from Justin to Kelly Justin to
Kelly from Rachel McAdams to Ryan
Gosling
yeah from Edward Bella Edwards Bella
cruel intentions
Ryan philippi Reese Witherspoon yeah but
that was like not really hello story it
was married Nick it's no no no I mean in
the movie yes it was it was like very
twisted he had cruel intentions no no
but in the end he totally left her
before he spoiler alert di Edie
yeah so it was very sad I mean they were
like the tragedy when they were in the
convertible just like running around the
Hamptons or whatever the town that was
supposed to be like that was true love
no but like he was mean he had was being
nefarious like cuz he wanted to take the
Headmaster's daughters virginity but the
whole point of the movie is that he
actually loved her right and he waited
for her Penn Station on the escalator
why that movie is so good except like
why did it have to end like that like I
don't know I guess that's why it's so
good I guess like would we would we have
thought it was so good to find
Philippine to them Alert die cheesy and
right like rom-com yeah okay third play
he's Bradley Cooper totally see it
fourth place Brad Pitt totally see it
fifth place George Clooney don't really
see it don't really see it George
Clooney's definitely like a handsome guy
but I think obviously the fact that he's
a billionaire an actor makes him more
handsome yeah like if he was you know
working at Trader Joe's I don't think
you would think he was out whereas if
Brad Pitt was working at Trader Joe's
like you would be like damn he's so hot
yeah sixth place
Hugh Jackman yeah that's a very
symmetrical box yeah but it's like not
my my personal aesthetic but I guess
that's why he's number six seventh place
David Beckham okay eighth place eater
selva totally I was literally gonna say
is there anyone not white on this list
nine place Kanye West which I think you
know really interesting no one really
low-key talks about how Connie is very
handsome like that smile that fotch he's
like a really like perfect looking
person no and I think Kim has to be on
the women's list somewhere to me she's
the definition of right well her new
Fox's okay but you could say the [ __ ]
totally um so like their kids really
should this will be a true test right I
thought it's like what do Cindy
Crawford's parents look like they wanted
models I don't know it's like Sid the
Liberty like this list doesn't take into
account like regular everyday people
yeah sure there's someone out there who
has a better ratio of Fox and Robert
Morris of course I mean have you heard
of Claudia have you heard of like Tyler
see have you heard of him but he's oh
speaking of we've agreed announcement
our she's gonna be on the show tomorrow
which is very exciting way to air
I literally don't know like I think my
bikini and then in 10th place is Ryan
Gosling Oh interesting coincidence so
all these people are famous and names
Ryan you know like I wanted I won the
- I guess go into the DMV database like
clear should use their database the DMV
database exactly and tell us whose
ratios on point yeah because it's it's
almost like unfair of people who have
enhanced faces make the list right you
know right and they're only making the
list because people know about them when
I'm like I'm over here with my perfect
face and nobody cares yeah it just
really wants me it makes me want to get
an enhanced face I I mean I am actually
making an appointment on Friday to have
some enhancements yeah it's time I don't
even know I need to go to like a Beverly
Hills doctor or the girls doing nothing
I'm gonna do it I'm just a nurse Jamie
that's where everyone goes that's just
like for necklines no no it's like for
everything we're an Elizabeth I think
has been talked about I talked to her
about it
okay all right speaking of this new
episode of mood with Lauren Elizabeth
now in the App Store and there's also a
new episode of date night and the motive
is snatcher will be up tomorrow we all
so much Thatcher tonight which is
actually good because we can talk to
Tyler see about it oh that's true is
tonight's episode one or two hours
probably two - probably three honestly
don't do that
okay next story a little fun young celeb
news riverdale star KJ app'
he posted a picture yesterday of him
kissing a mystery woman and it appears
he has confirmed that he's dating model
Clarabelle berry who does I don't know
she's beautiful though she has like a
perfect vouch he is actually had an
interesting career in the sense that
he's been famous for a long time as like
a young hot stud but hasn't actively
really dated anyone and a lot of people
use their dating life as like some sort
of launching pad for their career when I
feel like he hasn't done that so I
wonder I wonder where this is gonna take
him to next yeah I think it's gonna take
him he said it's love at first sight
sure so like I hope that just takes him
to happy land feels like he's being very
upfront no I mean I appreciate it so
much the Riverdale star appeared to
confirm his relationship with the 26
year old French model posting a photo of
himself kissing a woman whose face is
covered with a cap but it is believed to
be buried in Paris Coupe de foudre
application the romantic photo which
translate was a Coupe de foudre mature
lates from French to English as love at
first sight
Oh cute kukuku I love this he's so
handsome
he's so everything and I can't believe
he wasn't born a redhead
you know yeah some people are just
that's like it's just not believable
honestly yeah like he was in a dog's
purpose right he had brown hair and he's
a whole different man no but it's weird
he's also coming out with a movie soon
with Britt Robertson I love her to do
from the longest ride yeah and I'm so
excited to see it that's very exciting
yeah I'll let you guys know when it
comes out I'm happy for KJ app'
and I hope this is a you know the one
for him I hope so too or I hope it's a
good time you know everyone deserves
happiness he works hard yeah and you
know in a lot of ways I feel like you
were meant to be with KJ Appa just
because of the hair and that's literally
even a redhead right that's what's crazy
and would you move to Australia no I
don't know maybe he's in Canada maybe
you would hey Liam Hemsworth and his new
girlfriend though if you lived in
Australia that's true but I feel like I
would like Canada I mean I feel like I
would like anywhere that's not the city
no I know but like I do think that
Canada has higher taxes in America so I
don't think I could go but I really feel
like I could live in the Cayman Islands
you know in a big palace yeah I could
live in Switzerland it's just sit on my
offshore accounts no you know where I
really like actually like I guess I
don't think I would ever move there but
it's weird that I really like it so much
la yeah yeah I know oh my god that is
the shots of sunset theme song that's me
iconic that's me I liked LA - I couldn't
not live there I just don't really want
to live in a house because I find it
like scary and I wouldn't want to be
there alone and a lot of maintenance so
like I would need to live in like the
nicest apartment okay there's so many
nice apartments I know we would never
move there but I'm just saying I think
it's so crazy I think I'm an LA person I
think by the way Ben would definitely
move there for two years like for like
like not permanently should be like move
there for two years worked so hard to
see how far we get and then assess right
look are we only I mean I feel like we
work hard here and like it it
accelerates us but would we would we be
accelerating faster if we were in LA I
think so like look at our one week in LA
our la episodes we're at Dancing with
the Stars we were everywhere you that
was because we were only there for a
week like but like there are always
those opportunities like that's true
Hardy and now there are more parties in
New York than they are and I still say
no to all that me too because I even
though my 2020 resolution was to say yes
to life more and I am by the way I'm
going out of my house tonight you are
yeah
we out to dinner with you my friends fun
yeah I guess I'm seeing my friends
tomorrow night Pacific safer fun that's
very exciting okay um I feel like you
have something to say before our fifth
story it's just you know it's been hard
for me to sit here you know for whatever
time it has thirty minutes and not get
off my chest how obsessed I am with new
and more specifically because I got a
sneak peek of a new episode of The
Biggest Loser last night and it put me
in that mindset where I'm like I need to
get back on track on new it was such a
good episode I was crying like it's I
can't wait for the Biggest Loser to come
back when I was at the live method last
week I was talking to Matt our trainer
about Noom and he said he's heard
fabulous things and I was telling him
all about it and he was so into it and I
told you my doctor said the same thing
getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale it's
about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into that favorite pair of jeans is your
goal great but there are many reasons
why you might want to practice self-care
and every person is different because
we're different
NUMA just to your lifestyle they teach
you the psychology behind the decisions
you make and help you to keep track of
everything from workouts and steps to
analyzing your diet and recommending
healthy recipes new also connects you
with a personally assigned goal
specialist and a community of other
numers so you have all the support you
need to empower your change
NUMA is a habit changing solution that
helps users to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses based on psychology
Newman's not a diet it's a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life where no
food is considered good bad or
off-limits
they teach you moderation and can be
used in conjunction with many
preexisting popular diets if you want
Noom doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you how to
look at your own mind and make better
decisions for yourself NUMA is one of
the biggest and most accurate food
databases available that lets you track
meal habits visualize portion sizes and
see calorie density at a glance
glatons we're all strapped for time Noom
asked you to commit just 10 minutes a
day for yourself you don't have to
change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noon and oom
dot-com / toast what do you have to lose
visit new mom / toast to start your
trial today that's Noom dot-com / toast
sign on get your life together in a way
that's accessible and meaningful yeah um
I'm officially done drinking that coffee
like I'm seriously so they tell you not
to eat Tide Pods but that's what we're
doing you know also like the chem
coal's are not like it's bad I know it's
really bad I'm officially worried okay
I'm a keeper but there's a - story a
little oh [ __ ] you might like you can't
say ok can find a story a little without
it being busy but when it's not business
but it is still not so web news like
it's in it's a different kind of nails
food ok you know they just just don't
raise your eyebrows like that because
you get me all excited about the arms
and it's not the our final story a
little food news but we don't do food
news enough to like make up our own I
mean we're always talking about beyond
meat literally what the story is okay
because we talk about them all the time
yes um Sabra is finally not that nobody
asked for this
Sabra is releasing chocolate hummus just
in time for Valentine's Day [ __ ]
disgusting you've probably heard that
chocolate hummus exists by this point no
I did not know that the first widely
sold versions of the savory sweet snack
debuted in 2018 received tons of mixed
reactions but one big hummus company has
noticeably stayed out of the competition
until now
yes Sabra hummus is finally adding a
chocolate hummus to their lineup
people can exclusively reveal the
company's new dark chocolate dessert dip
and spread will be released in honor of
Valentine's Day it features a rich
chocolate taste that's made with cooked
chickpeas soybean oil cocoa sea salt and
vanilla extract among others unlike
Sabra other hummus flavors the new
plant-based chocolate dip does not
contain tahini thank God this is so
disgusting literally nobody asks for
this I didn't know this was a thing
before I will never try this and
honestly Sabra is continuing to
disappoint me in ways that I didn't know
it was possible like first their
terrible Superbowl commercial where they
spent probably 50 million dollars to put
1 million celebrities in a commercial
4.5 seconds and now just like this
tragedy that is chocolate hummus shame
on you yeah I mean I'm now just curious
to try it because apparently they have
it at Trader Joe's and people do like it
I mean and if Sabra is really like
invested investing in this product
there's the thing is it like Nutella but
it's maybe chickpeas that's disgusting
or maybe it's a tasty and happens to be
healthy I think you should try it live
on the show I think I should what do you
dip with it though like a strawberry
oh maybe definitely
like carrots or like a chip or maybe
like a little cracker pretzel cinnamon
cracker a pretzel yeah yeah or like a
finger you should do a tasting I hate
hummus and I don't think I would like
chocolate hummus either I'm sorry
chocolate homeless yeah thank you for
that sorry I mean it's like I forgot my
heritage or something whenever I think
of homos I think of that movie I said
the Zohan no but that is a good one too
that cartoon movie sausage party I never
saw where you didn't husband's are
obsessed with it
you know the premise of the movie was
incredibly stupid but I thought that
first of all the animation was brilliant
and the the context of like all these
foods a lot of like the food puns they
were very brilliant and like the aisles
and like the food jokes was really funny
but like the premise of like I'm trying
to break out of the supermarket was so
dumb but there's like a middle-eastern
aisle where like the Jewish bagels and
like the Arab like falafel are like you
know who moves my cousin it was really
funny yeah and just like a great way to
tackle you know a hot topic 100% um so
let's talk my bender from pearls okay I
this is gonna be a short segment because
I really like thought it was a waste of
an episode but I don't know if it's
because the episode stunk or because I
was busy watching my tick-tock the
entire time I definitely think was a
combination of both I didn't think it
was such a bad episode but I definitely
think it was a good one like I could
have completely skipped over this
episode into next week and I feel like I
wouldn't have missed anything well the
moral of the story is that Stassi and
Kristen temporarily made up even though
Stassi was on watch repens live saying
it's 50/50 if Kristen's gonna be invited
to her wedding
Katie and her the wedge grew even bigger
and further um they just can't seem to
agree on anything and I just feel like
any fights or any makeups happening on a
bachelorette party in Miami um are null
and void like these people are theirs
Kristen is so drunk having these
conversations like they don't really
mean anything but the fight did exist
before the bachelor party I feel like
when they go home it'll be the same as
when they left they left also they were
staying at the SLS which was bringing me
back to when we went to the SLS and when
Sonja Morgan went to the SLS pool I had
a nervous breakdown yeah I completely
understood because I'm where she was
coming from because there's something
about that pool that's just like not it
it's just so weird how like these people
are like huge mega stars but when they
go on these trips like on Gina's
bachelor bachelorette party to say that
the dream in Miami was just like not
exactly the nicest hotel it's so strange
how the life they live
off camera is more like elevated than
the life I live on camera which you
think would be the onset why did they go
to Miami for both like why not go to SLS
in Bahamas I just like you know for
Mexico like to go to Miami from LA so
they do always what in Mexico yeah but
you go to Miami from LA is like such a
trip like honestly go to Paris like
you're going across the country like
take a trip no the the actual trip
itself was just like bumming me out
except for when they dressed up his old
man I thought that was like his rules at
its best Thomas and of all was a
recognizable I knew who Jax was I knew
who I was that kind of knew Schwartz was
I know who Jax was I could not figure
out that he actually looked so different
yeah they did a really good job
excellent job and Jax literally like
peeling his face off with a butter knife
the next morning like I felt his I
empathized before he's like level of
uncomfortableness yeah that was they
committed they went to a strip club they
went to 11:00 looks like they all had a
good time nothing really happened once
again I find myself
perplexed by the whole Kristen drama I
do feel like everyone is being so short
with her she's definitely you know not
handling the break-up as well as she
could but like give her a break so it's
literally the same fight we've been
having this conversation for the last
three episodes he said was I completely
agree with Harry that I feel bad that
I'm not there for you yeah and I and I
will always be there for you like you
weren't one of my best friends and and
and that's all that needs to be said at
the end of the day but honestly they
were making it seem like they weren't
gonna be there first so Kristen was like
freaking out yeah because I said like
this is not they literally were being so
final they were like who wants to be
friends like yeah when scheana was like
maybe some friendships aren't me Jean
our lives for like a divide in The
Witches of WeHo cuz she thinks maybe
once and for all she'll become one of
them no but when she was talking to
Chris and she was like if you can't say
how you feel and like be yourself and
you know then that's not a friendship
and but that's always like what people
were saying to her about her time with
the witches of WeHo it's like she can't
be herself right I think she shouldn't
be friend she's just living for this
yeah yeah yeah the weirdest thing is
also that Sheena and Peter are sharing a
room like I don't think I'll ever get
over that I will never get over that
knowing that they probably are getting
majorly discounted rooms because like
not really SLS participating they're
filming they're all emotive nerves so I
like I just can't understand no it's so
strange maybe one of those people who
just doesn't like to be in a hotel room
alone that's me but like I would rather
be alone than be with my
male coworker you're actually your
former manager ma'am right right like I
would literally rather sleep in the
hallway you know yeah it's just so weird
um another weird thing oh no we were
thinking about spending manager oh yes
so now we go back to LA oh I had a
conversation on Instagram with Dana
because I tell her in a story I was like
I just love this [ __ ] and she literally
wrote to me she's not even following you
for years I love you so much I can't
believe that you're saying such nice
things about me I'm like oh my god I
love you like good for you for like
taking these serb [ __ ] and not giving
them any of your time and she was like
bad recognize as bad and I was like yes
we do [ __ ] it was such a great moment
for women I'm so happy for you
everything that comes out of her mouth
every situation that she handles is just
to a tee like I when someone was telling
her about max like you know cheating on
this former girl I don't even know what
the right thing to do in that situation
is because of you
if you ignore it then you just like are
a girl like in the words of Kent had a
stupid woman yeah but if you act on it
immediately like you're then you're
Peter Webber just acting on all these
red flags before we've seen it and she
literally said the perfect thing she's
like literally last week you wouldn't
even acknowledge me now you're
quote/unquote my friend like giving me
good advice like these [ __ ] are so
jealous of Dana one because max actually
likes her too because she doesn't care
about them and three she doesn't let
them get under her skin like she's so
unfazed by all of their [ __ ] like I
love her I'm not like crazy about the
new people drama but like dana has to
say on the show forever I need her to
become friends Olalla like I need her to
move move on up past these losers Danica
it's such a [ __ ] loser the suspended
manager she's such a mean girl she does
whatever people tell her to do and she
just does what she thinks like will get
her on TV yeah and when she was taught
saying in her confessional like Dana
trying to convince me that max is a good
guy like she did nothing of the sort
no she doesn't care about you she's not
talking to you doesn't care about your
opinion wait that Dana handled it like
she wasn't being fake but she was being
like Hannah and she was like I thank you
so much I hear you I see you I
appreciate you I'm just gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] I want it was so
brilliant like brilliant I wish that I
was that cool you know like to remain
when you know she know exactly what
Danica was doing like they're just all
trying to [ __ ] with her for some reason
because they're so jealous of her but
also I think they're also like this is a
TV show it's a new cast like they need
to you know throw someone under the bus
they need to make their mark yeah they
need a punching bag and they think it's
gonna be her and she is nothing she
refuses to be it and I just love her and
her max are so cute and she can't be it
like she's genuinely too cool like it
doesn't work that way
she needs to it like she'd say
graduate from Sur and like become
friends with everyone because she's so
cool yeah well next week when Sheena is
talking to Lisa and Lisa is like are you
jealous of her and then Sheena breaks
down about jealousy and then she talks
to ten uh Dana being like you are trying
to steal all my friends like it's so
much bigger than we even thought it's
not just Max it's like what friends like
Lala and the girls and she's friends
with them no but like Tina met them one
day and they all really liked her sorry
she's cool sorry sorry sorry it was a
another thing about a pretty boring
episode we didn't see James or Raquel at
all but next week is Pride where James
deejays and he obviously pretends like
he's entering anymore and then calls
Raquel a [ __ ] or something yeah for not
showing up to his DJ set like a
two-year-old I'm giving up to my play
like I can't is always a good episode so
yeah like that'll be it there's just so
many characters like it's truly
difficult to keep up let me say they
were like I can just hate like I see it
from here yes maybe if you burp some
bubbles will come out let's do tear
toasters which is our advice segment if
you want to get involved and have some
advice of ours of yours read on the air
completely anonymously please email us
dear toasters at gmail.com and the dear
toaster segment is brought to you by zip
recruiter that's actually a great
sponsor for Deere toasters right because
everyone helpful and everyone's having
workplace drama like if you want to get
out head to zip recruiter Dylan Miska
wits is a real zip recruiter customer
who use zip recruiter to hire for his
company he is a CEO and his experience
challenging how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching for a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company but then he switched to
zip recruiter and saw an immediate
difference and you've can too by signing
up for free ads if were crude or calm /
toast zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you and it's technology identifies
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job so you
get qualified candidates faster in fact
after posting has dropped a zipper Kurt
or Dylan said he was amazed by how
quickly great candidates were applying
and found his new director of coffee in
just a few days with results like that
it's still wonderful out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
seewhy zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our web address
zip recruiter dot-com / toast
that's zip recruiter
/ TOA st zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire love it saina hire well okay I'm
very excited for some of these zipper
facilities dip recruiters for some of
these here toasters again - your
toasters at gmail.com is our email
address submission submission box
suggestion box
dear toasters I recently got very sick
and was in the hospital I was honestly
it was honestly a very humbling and
scary experience while being so sick I
promised I was going to better myself
I wanted to seriously cut back on
drinking and be more responsible about
my sexual activities so since being
healthy and fulfilling my promise I have
grown I've grown a bush
I hate pubes and seriously I haven't had
a day since I was maybe 14 every day I
think to myself okay make an appointment
to get a wax but then I'm like why this
is preventing me and making it a hundred
percent sure that I don't do anything
with anyone but it's driving me insane
and I hate it
so toasters that's a question here to
wax or let the bush grow ooh interesting
that isn't an age old question max we're
not - well there's a middle ground like
you can have a bush that'll still like
keep men away that isn't that's more
kept and like it's called a like a pair
of cuticle cutters like a little scissor
you got a little trim you still have a
full bush but like it's not coming
through your panties you know yeah but I
feel like also if what you want to do is
not sleep with people then you should be
done like now the bush has helped you
like achieve that goal that goal like
and you don't want to have the bush like
maybe get rid of the bush and see if you
can do it on your own you know what I
think she said I recently got very sick
so I don't think it's been enough time
okay well maybe you could like and
honestly I commend your efforts and
that's a really good way to do it I just
think there's a middle ground you don't
have to have like a full 70s bush or
like a few prepubescent [ __ ] like
there's something go get a landing strip
yeah there's just there's a middle
ground but you can what get a bikini wax
and trim or you could even like shave so
it like comes back they'll come back
quicker it doesn't cut yourself like
yeah but that is going to the rule if
you shave you're ruining years of waxing
and your hair is gonna come back in
different don't do that actually get a
bikini wax and a trim yeah a weed
whacker yeah this is so funny but then I
think eventually like I mean ultimately
you should do what you're comfortable
with and not because it's what a guy is
gonna like or
not like you should have the vision that
you wish to see in the world and
hopefully you know these years of
training with the bush can help you like
and have that sort of willpower zeal to
hook up with people but it's not year
she said I recently got sick okay
month week month okay I'm assuming I
just think keep going girl I'm happy for
you you know that I am here's our second
one thank you for writing in hi Jackie
and Claudia my cousin is in her mid-20s
and she's never been kissed
we are very opposite when it comes to
our social lives she never went to high
school dances and attended a small
college I've been very outgoing my whole
life have dated had boyfriends
throughout high school and college I'm
asking for advice on how to give her a
gentle nudge to get out there and
explore herself while safely dating
she's always given 110 % to her job in
school I normally wouldn't be concerned
with her life decisions but after a
recent conversation we had in regards to
online dating she said she really isn't
interested in dating and if it happens
it happens if it doesn't it doesn't I
love her so much and I want her to be
happy and not live with life's what-ifs
she's always wanted to be a mom and give
so much to others I know it's mainly
self confidence that's holding her back
but I'm rated will only get worse with
time
any advice on how to approach his topic
lately thanks so much I've got this one
I had a friend who is exactly like that
who had no interest in meeting someone
she was like oh if I do then great but
like if it comes to me yeah like she was
more so interested in her friendships
and everything else that wasn't romantic
and one day we were having a
conversation where I was like you should
like try and meet someone and instead of
just like telling her why we sat down
they made her a dating profile or you
can't just tell someone like you have to
help them right and you have to make it
exciting so like we sat there he picked
her best pictures I mean answer
questions we had fun with it and then we
even like did some swipes and like it
was just exciting to see like there were
actually really cute guys out there and
then a friend is engaged now friend is
engaged to someone she met on him
someone that the first person that she
went out with from making her dapple
that's just beginner's luck that is
beginner's luck um but I do think and
then also there is something like fun
and gaming about the app and then when
you have a profile no one wants to sit
alone and make their own profile and
think about what's great about them but
when you have a friend who helps you do
and it encourages you it makes it fun
and then you have this like bang in
profile right stats are ready to go and
then you can sit at home and like swipe
and swipe and then it is very gratifying
and dating apps are a perfect way to
start dating because if you're waiting
for something to come to you it can just
come to you if you're on an app but you
have to just take the
step of being on an applic it's a very
small step and I feel like if you're
really just the type of person who's not
gonna actively like swipe but wait for
someone to message you like they can't
message you without a profile right and
I think the most daunting part is making
that profile um no one wants to do it
themselves so do it with a friend a lot
of people are commenting oh my god this
is me like this is actually great advice
do it with a friend
make it a fun night you go through all
your pictures like it just it's actually
a really fun activity I've done it with
a lot of my friends and they've all
eventually met someone from a dating app
I think that's great the segment should
be sponsored by henge um it doesn't have
to be hinge there's a lot of good ones
OkCupid yes remember if you meet someone
OkCupid I'll come to your wedding okay
under that rule applies if you get
someone else yeah this person what goes
the other person's a toaster yeah well
I'm sure they're gonna be like who are
these two strangers at my wedding
[Laughter]
okay third and final dear toasters
Jackie and Claudia longtime listener
first-time writer this is not your
typical dear toasters email recently my
dog Rio has displayed a special talent
Rio
you know I'm obsessive that dog in the
field our dream is to have dogs named
Theo jeah Rio and Leo he is a special
talent he's able to predict outcomes of
critical life moments for example he has
accurately guessed the sex of babies the
outcome of the past Super Bowl mind you
I'm a 49ers fan and he has the dis mate
of this entire pack hehehe to the dismay
of his entire pack picked the Chiefs
among other things my god she just
watches the toast in new my question is
do I sound crazy if I pursue this as a
career with Rio as a social media
superstar what is your advice for taking
his talents to the next level Thank You
Rio and his mom okay you know what like
there's way crazier things out like
PS Olivia's having a girl according to
Rio Wow
how does Rio choose honestly it sounds
fascinating right honestly if it's true
like this sounds like something that
needs to be on The Tonight Show ya know
like this sounds like the Hollywood
medium you know so I think you should
totally pursue that find a way to
capture what he does I don't know how he
chooses a team does he speak English and
film videos I think people have people
like right into you and ask you a
question like don't quit your job yes
but just sounds like a really fun
passion project hobby that the world
could benefit from yeah and if you're
looking to make premium content but you
don't have like the photoshop skills
we've recently started using canva and
it
such a great platform agree like we are
graphic designers now right and we can
barely like put our you know we now make
a graphic for everything that gets weird
I love making good I think this is
definitely something that you should
pursue first as a hobby see if they
gains traction even if it doesn't but
you enjoy it then it doesn't need
traction because that's what a hobby is
or it could become something much bigger
but I think this is fabulous for you in
Rio and I'm all about it and we love the
name Rio and we love it because Jackie
has been you know teasing me for years
that she's gonna end up getting a dog
and she wants the name to rhyme with
Theo so she had giome she had well I
would say Gio was short version Carlo
now Rio is a good one yeah Leo and Cleo
if there is a girl I like Cleo I think
Leo's actually too similar to do I think
but if they were like a foursome like if
each of the sisters had a Cavalier Leo
that would be unstoppable I just really
wish today of all days we had the fee
okay I'm because for the first time in
his history Theo has been on the show
and not moved once he's dead asleep
maybe had like a really intense walk
this morning with his walker maybe that
was it yeah but he is dat like he also
didn't have a coffee today so but his
belly's moving I'm always like he's
sleeping so still is he dead no he's
breathing don't worry yeah okay well
remised are some really good deer
toasters and I feel like I gave seller
advice also I saw someone commented that
they have for dating profiles and
there's been absolutely nothing
happening for them and my hypothesis is
that your profiles aren't neato
revamping or they're restrictive like
you only want someone within 1 mile
radius of your house yeah you uh maybe
your standards are too high but if
you're not getting like swipes on you
sometimes like your photos the there's a
there's a formula like the first one has
to be a solo shot of you limited amounts
of photos with sunglasses limited
amounts of photos with other people and
you just like don't be like to corporate
LinkedIn but also don't be to like a
grand party girl so true it's a delicate
balance or guy thank you by the way tear
toasters we didn't do last week because
we've them in really getting great ones
so I put something on our Instagram
yesterday and I think we got a bunch of
responses but deer toasters is what you
make it so please don't be shy we always
keep it anonymous deer toasters at
gmail.com
thank you so much at noon today Eastern
Time the toast dirty jeans tour merch is
dropping at shop morning toast calm hats
koozies and sweaters and long sleeve
t-shirts all limited stocks so make sure
you go to shop morning toast calm I post
about it on our Instagram to remind you
with swipe up links
that's all we got for you thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube we are also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
may be found so that's about if I iTunes
stitcher Public Radio iHeartRadio
cashbox wherever you choose to listen to
podcast please find us the morning toast
leave a five star review if you want
maybe a comment about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much have an amazing day be
we'll see you tomorrow with Tyler
Cameron from The Bachelorette but in the
meantime enjoy our segment with Reza
Farhan from Shahs of Sunset also check
out my tick-tock at Jackie O